While it’s likely others had tried it before,
the first surviving documented attempt of
someone trying to turn something to gold in
a (relatively) scientific fashion occurred
around 300 AD.
The proto-scientist in question was a Greco-Egyptian
named Zosimos.
During his lifetime, it’s thought that he
wrote nearly thirty books about alchemy, but
most of them have been lost to history.
What we do know is that in his work he focused
mainly on the use of vapors, specifically
sulfur vapors which do cause some things to
turn yellow.
For example, he found that when mixed with
liquid mercury, the resulting substance becomes
a yellow solid, but it wasn’t gold.
From there for nearly two thousand years famed
scientists like Isaac Newton, Roger Bacon,
Robert Boyle, and Jabir ibn Hayyan all tried
their hand at making gold.
All failed, but did give the world numerous
other advancements as a result of their work.
As science historian Lawrence Principe noted
in 2014, they “were amazingly good experimentalists.”
This brings us to more modern times and one
of the most distinguished scientists of the
20th century you’ve probably never heard
of- Glenn T. Seaborg.
Seaborg was far from being a no-name chemist
with a crazy vision of turning lead into gold
when he decided to make the attempt in 1980.
For example, in 1941, he led the team that
first discovered/produced/isolated the element
plutonium.
This led to the United States pursuing a program
to make plutonium for use in their atomic
bomb project, which later morphed into the
top-secret Manhattan Project which Seaborg
also worked on.
(Although, along with many other scientists
who worked on the project, he strongly lobbied
for doing a public demonstration of a nuclear
explosion to show to Japan, rather than actually
using the bomb against them.)
All in all during his lifetime he helped discover
ten elements (via creating them in a lab),
which ultimately saw him receive a Nobel Prize
in chemistry in 1951.
He also discovered or helped isolate well
over 100 isotopes, most notably Iodine-131,
which if you’ve ever known someone with
certain thyroid diseases (including some types
of thyroid cancer), they may well still be
alive, or have had their life extended, thanks
to this one.
Along the way he became the chairman for the
Atomic Energy Commission, advising and working
for US Presidents Kennedy, Johnson, and Nixon.
During his time in that role, he successfully
lobbied for the nuclear test ban treaty prohibiting
the testing of nuclear devices in the atmosphere
or under the sea.
He also strongly advocated for increased funding
for science education in schools, better science
curriculum, and increased funding in pure
scientific research.
He’s also the only chemist in history to
have an element named after him while he was
still living- seaborgium.
This brings us to creating gold.
In 1980, the Seaborg and a group of other
scientists used a particle accelerator to
propel beams of carbon and neon nuclei at
nearly light speed into foils of the heavy
metal bismuth- you know, the stuff you find
in relatively large quantities in Peptol-Bismol,
used for shotgun pellets, and a variety of
other applications.
Why bismuth, rather than the originally planned
lead?
It is simply easier to isolate gold from bismuth
than it is from lead.
However, producing gold from lead would have
been no more difficult.
As for the result, when they were rifling
through the carnage that was the result of
the high speed collision between neon, carbon,
and bismuth, the physicists discovered the
they had successfully made several isotopes
of gold.
Of course, none of this was economical in
the slightest.
According to Seaborg, “It would cost more
than one quadrillion dollars per ounce to
produce gold by this experiment.”
The going rate for gold in 1980 was about
$590 an ounce…
Still, regardless of cost, finally after at
least a couple thousand years of effort by
some of the finest minds in history, a human
had finally created gold from
something else.